yesterday I did a couple of segments
about the targeting of trans people and
drag shows and the LGBT community in the
wake of the horrible shooting in
Nashville Tennessee one of the things I
mentioned but didn't end up having time
for and I want to talk about it now is
the claim that trans people are
targeting Christians now before we move
on to the generality of Tucker Carlson
making this claim
I do want to remind folks that the
shooter in Nashville who was trans had a
history with that school and so it's
very hard in that particular case to
make the argument that trans people and
the movement is targeting Christians but
even more generally I'm going to argue
with you argue to you I'll argue with
you if you want to argue with me but I
will argue to you
uh that the claim that the trans
movement is targeting Christians is
absurd and in fact lb lgbtq people are
way more likely to be the victims of
violence including from those who say I
don't like you because of my Christian
worldview than they are to be the
perpetrators of violence at all never
mind against Christian individuals
Rolling Stone article says Tucker
Carlson claims trans movement is
targeting Christians amid calls for gun
control
the article says lgbtq people are much
more often likely to be the victims of
targeted Mass violence than perpetrators
Tucker Carlson did this nonsense on his
opening monologue I'm gonna play it for
you and then we will discuss
the trans movement is targeting
Christians including with violence that
is wrong
most Christian leaders in this country
don't want to admit that admitting it
might force them to take deeply
unfashionable positions but it is true
and anyone who's paying attention knows
that it's true and so like most true
things at this point it is officially
suppressed now that is also part of the
story
part of getting your audience to believe
insane untrue things
is priming them that the reason they
might not hear this insane untrue thing
elsewhere isn't because it's untrue it's
because it's being suppressed elsewhere
which of course it's not that the trans
movements Vendetta against Christianity
is being suppressed it's that it doesn't
exist
anywhere Beyond resentment over those
who weaponize their Christian faith
against trans people here for example is
Joe Biden yelping again about how it's
all your fault when these tragedies
happen because you've got guns at home
this is from yesterday
we have room to do more to stop con
violence it's ripping our communities
apart ripping a soul this nation and rip
it's a very soul of the nation
and we we have to do more to protect our
schools so they aren't turned into
prisons
you know the shooter in this situation
reportedly had two assault weapons and a
pistol to ak-47.
so I call on Congress again to pass my
assault weapons ban
so we're going to prevent you from
learning why the shooter did it and we
don't have to guess because she wrote a
whole Manifesto about why she did it and
we know that she did that because she
told a friend of hers on Instagram that
she did it but we can't see it we can
only talk about the guns we can't know
what kind of drugs she was taking what
kind of hormones or ssris or
benzodiazepines there it is
Ben I I hate to tell you folks
benzos causing a mass shooting does not
sound like the most informed take I've
ever heard and then of course it's
coming from Tucker Carlson not from a
medical professional we can only talk
about the guns past my assault weapons
ban that'll fix the problem now of
course we can talk about much more than
the guns if they want to talk about
mental illness we should talk about
mental illness and I do but they don't
want to actually fund access to mental
health treatment if they want to talk
about the toxic gun culture of the
United States I would gladly talk about
that they will never even bring that up
they don't want to acknowledge that and
yes we should also talk about the guns
now there's one other aspect to this not
only is this brazenly untrue that the
trans movement is targeting Christians
the trans movement doesn't want violent
rhetoric or discrimination from anybody
no matter the origins of that in some
cases it is Christianity that is being I
would argue being misused they would say
it's just we're just looking at
scripture I would say it is being
misused
to Target the trans Community but
there's another aspect to this
to some extent many of these folks see
not being Christian
as hostile to Christianity
you can be non-religious that doesn't
mean you're targeting Christianity you
could be Muslim or Jewish or Buddhist or
whatever
and not be targeting Christianity but a
lot of these folks the mere absence of
Christianity is targeting Christianity
and this is part of the problem for some
of the for a wing of the American
Evangelical Community simply not being
an Evangelical Christian they claim as
an attack on their faith and and last
thing there are also trans people who
are Christian I think it's important to
say